Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
We just learned some more details
about Marvel's plans for the Iron Man franchise
behind the scenes obviously we
see Robert Downey Jr, Joe Rogan talking
about Iron Man eventually coming back.
Most of what they talked about
have actually come to pass
like they Babe
Ruth style called that shot.
We learn more about
what would have been the Iron Man
four movie and the truth
about Tom Cruise's version of Iron Man.
So there was a whole bunch of stuff.
We'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
We're also in the middle
of that Spider-Man
to game give away our name
a new winner during this video
and there is like a weird spam
bot going around in the comments
pretending to message people on Telegram
about some giveaway stuff.
That's not me, that's a spammer.
But I think most of you have figured out
that it's actually a fake person.
it's one of those big problems
that everybody with big channels
has but YouTube refuses to fix.
Hopefully they'll do something about it
soon.
but a bunch of this new Iron Man
information
of what's going on with the character
behind
the scenes comes from a book
about the truth of Marvel Studios.
Like All the Dirt
you could ever Want on Marvel Studios,
It's called The Reign of Marvel Studios.
It was written
by a couple acquaintances of mine.
This video isn't like an ad for the book
or anything.
I wasn't paid any money to talk about it,
but it is a really cool book.
all these new details on the Iron Man
character, what's going on with him
just in general are just a small piece of
what's in the book like.
It's way, way bigger than that.
a lot of you been wondering why Iron Man
four never got turned into a movie,
why they killed off the 616 version
of Iron Man in Avengers Endgame, Thor
got Love and Thunder, His fourth movie,
they just announced they're doing Thor
five with another director like Taika
Waititi isn't coming back.
I just did another video
about that a while ago, so I'll link it.
Blown the description
They're doing Captain America
for next year,
even though all these movies seem like
they're getting delayed a little bit.
Why not do a fourth movie
for their most popular character?
seems like that would have been
a slam dunk during Marvel Phase four.
It would have come right after Avengers
Endgame, just like Thor,
Love and Thunder in.
Some of you
probably will not be surprised by this.
Like this Apply confirms some theories
that you've had behind the scenes.
But turns out Robert Downey
Jr did not want to get his character
killed off in Avengers Endgame
like he didn't want Iron Man to die.
And when the studio told him
what the story of Infinity War and Endgame
were going to be, he basically
gave them a polite No, thank you.
like, how about
we not get rid of the Iron Man character
I also think that Marvel
is on this journey now of they're trying
a bunch of other stuff and it lets,
you know, I'm excited for them
to see how all that goes
and it's hard to it's hard to project,
if you haven't heard about what
Robert Downey
Jr's experience was like behind the scenes
of all of his Marvel movies,
like his own Iron Man movies, The Avengers
movies, essentially because of the way
his contract worked out.
He lived like a king,
and everybody loved working with him.
He loved working with everyone else.
Like it was actually genuinely
a really good experience for all of them.
so he was totally fine
keeping the good times rolling.
I'm sure the money didn't hurt either.
they would have gone on
to make Iron Man for
he would have continued to operate
in the MCU the same way he'd been doing
during Marvel Phase three, like
appearing in a couple cameos occasionally.
Then again in Avengers, Kane, Dynasty
in Secret Wars, so on and so forth.
in. Originally,
the alternate ending for Avengers
Endgame was to have Captain
America wield the Infinity gantlet.
He'd snap it, then die as a result.
so originally they were planning on having
Captain America wield Thor's Hammer,
then wield the Infinity Gantlet.
it's a real big moment in the comics, too.
But in that version of events,
there was no time travel mission
that he had at the end of the movie where
he stayed with Peggy Carter in the past.
No moment at the very end when he returns
as an old man in the main timeline
and gives the shield to Falcon in
the funeral would have been for him.
Obviously not for Iron Man.
So it would have been
a completely different vibe, completely
different ending for Avengers Endgame
in apparently in the writers room.
Kevin Feige, the Russos, the writers
eventually decided that they wanted
to give Captain America
that Peggy Carter reunion ending,
and at least in the room,
it made more sense than that.
They'd have to have Iron Man
be the one to snap the infinity gantlet.
and because most fans
would go into the scene of Iron
Man snapping the Infinity gantlet,
expecting him to have some creative work
around, enabling him to survive the snap
in order to surprise people like Big
W, to have surprise in the theater
as much as possible.
They legit kill him off.
there were so many fan theories
after Avengers
Endgame came out about how Iron Man
could have survived the snap
and he probably could have like
you could actually write a way
for him to survive
that and for it to make sense.
but the other big idea behind the scenes
at Marvel as Kevin Foggy, one of the movie
two, feel like a definitive ending
for the original six Avengers in
what could be more final than killing off
some of your characters
fast forward to Marvel.
Phase four, Everything that Robert Downey
Jr, Joe Rogan,
we're talking about a couple of years ago
actually came to pass.
Legit.
They totally called it like Marvel Phase
four was extremely divisive.
There have been a couple bangers,
but Marvel is now heading towards a soft
reboot of the MCU with secret wars
to clean up their continuity
fold in a bunch of X-Men.
Fantastic Four characters
just help everything to make sense.
Just a clean up things in the background
that they want to clean up.
is part of that.
They sort of to bring back
all these original actors
in as part of the reboot announcement
around Secret Wars.
There was also a quote from Kevin Foggy
that I talked about in earlier video
about this,
basically saying that they would be using
that twist to bring back dead characters
in different ways,
which is how they bring back Robert Downey
Jr as another version of Iron Man.
But they don't have to bring back
the one that died in Endgame.
They just want to have Robert Downey
Jr come back as a version of Iron Man.
There are a number of ways
to explain that,
primarily either
time travel or an alternate universe.
now they're doing the Iron Man Armor Wars
series as a movie
that's supposed to happen during Marvel
Phase six. That hasn't changed.
It'll mostly be about Rhodey
in an adaptation of the Armor Wars
comic book series
Ultron is supposed to come back.
Damage control Valve is supposed to be
the main antagonist, like damage control
is supposedly going to accidentally
bring Ultron back when they try to mess
with Iron Man. Stark
Tech and Rhodey has to deal with that.
But here's the thing.
Here's like a new wrinkle
with bringing Robert Downey Jr back.
Normally it'd be no big deal
to bring him up and pay him
a small trash bag of money
to come back for a few cameo scenes
like Here, please take our money,
come back for a couple of minutes.
he's probably going to be nominated
for an Oscar for his performance
in the Oppenheimer movie.
And he said that when he made that movie,
it reminded him
what real acting was like.
I remember that I'm an actor.
I can actually act now.
just because of the way
they make Marvel movies very differently
from other normal movies.
Like it doesn't feel like traditional
acting to a lot of actors.
so he gets nominated for Oppenheimer.
Everybody remembers how awesome an actor
he actually is in normal movies,
and it just reinvigorates his interest
in doing non Marvel movies.
So I definitely think that they will
eventually recast the main version of Iron
Man with a younger actor at some point.
But because Kevin Feige said that they
would continue to explore the multiverse
in future Marvel movies
like Marvel, Phase seven and beyond,
they'll just say that Robert Downey
Jr is Iron Man exists in an alternate
universe and just bring him back
if they ever want to.
and when it comes to bringing him back
for a cameo and say, like Secret Wars,
I think that there's give him
to trash bags of money Like that
Oscar will just require
an extra trash bag of money.
as for Tom Cruise's version of Iron Man,
there was a lot of talk about this one
doctor strange multiverse of Madness
came out like him coming to Cameo
as a version Super Iron Man
in how it was a big meta Easter egg
for the original version of the character.
He almost wound up playing
back in the early 2000s.
this new book on Marvel Studios
actually explains
what really happened with Tom Cruise's
version of Iron Man, back
during the early 2000s, Marvel
and Fox were developing an Iron Man
movie like way before
the original Fantastic Four movies period.
This is like original X-Men era
when the first couple of X-Men
movies were coming out
Tom Cruise was the first actor
that they were developing the movie with,
Johnny Depp was also on their short list
because before he made the Pirates
of the Caribbean movies.
so Johnny Depp was also almost Iron Man
in the main reason
why that version of the Iron Man movie
fell apart in the early 2000
was because Tom
Cruise asked for way too much money
what Fox and Marvel considered an untested
character like.
They weren't confident that
the Iron Man character was popular enough,
like the X-Men
had been popular to earn enough money
to justify what he was asking for.
the book doesn't really get into the weeds
on like exactly what it was
he asked for.
I'm assuming
it was about $20 million plus,
like a giant percentage
of the actual box office.
it even though I think that Marvel
made the right call
and just waiting and eventually
doing the Robert Downey
Junior version of Iron Man like it
couldn't have gone better for them, like
he was the perfect actor for the role.
eventually they wound up paying
Robert Downey Jr money like that.
Like basically his contract
inflated to like 70 so million
dollars per movie
by the final two Avengers movies.
that is basically Tom Cruise level money
like he earns about that amount of money
on all of his Mission Impossible movies
there was even a funny video
where Jon Favreau and Kevin
Foggy were talking about the history
of the Iron Man character
and how felicitous it was that they cast
Robert Downey Junior.
Like, it couldn't have gone better.
Like we made the best possible choice that
anybody could have made in casting him.
but around the time they were developing
this Tom Cruise
version of the Iron Man movie,
they were also developing the original
Fantastic Four movies in Robert Downey Jr.
Almost wound up
playing Doctor Doom in those movies.
can you even imagine what all the Marvel
movies landscape would look like
now if things had gone down that way?
Like I do think that everything worked out
the way it should have worked out.
Like Robert Downey
Jr wound up being Iron
Man and things could not have been better.
Let me know in the comments.
If you want to see Iron Man
cameo before Secret Wars And when Marvel
eventually recast the Iron Man character,
who do you want to play him?
Right.
Now, I will say that I'm totally fine
in it, being a completely unknown actor.
Like just wait a couple of years
after secret
wars, like,
don't try to recast him right away.
Just like give it a little bit of time,
then eventually fold him in.
there's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
My Full Loki Season
two Episode four Video will post next.
Be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
And congratulations Noir.
Ah, you're the giveaway winner
for my last big Spider-Man video.
Please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your contact details.
click here for that new Loki Episode
4 Video.
Update the link as soon as I post
that and click here to learn about what's
going on with the Big Marvel reboot.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!